the German government has confirmed it's
been informed that the u.s. is
considering a partial withdrawal of
American troops from the country this
follows media reports that President
Donald Trump had ordered the removal of
nearly 10,000 troops from Germany almost
a third of the US military personnel
stationed in the country a German
government spokesperson said that while
they've been notified a final decision
is yet to be made by the US DW
correspondent teri Schultz joins me now
forum from Brussels Terry do we know why
the Trump administration might want to
withdraw over a quarter of its troops
from Germany we don't Thierry it makes
absolutely no strategic sense you know
there are these stories floating around
that he's angry at Chancellor Merkel
again for Germany's very low defense
spending it won't reach the 2 percent
level for more than another decade at
best or that he's angry at her for not
agreeing to come to a g7 summit this
month because she said you know the
stage of the coronavirus threat is
simply not at a point where I want to
travel there is no reason militarily
that the US should want to pull troops
out of Germany it's probably the major
military hub in Europe and it's used not
as president Trump often portrays it to
protect Germany or protect protect
Europe but as a staging ground and a
training ground for US operations
elsewhere in the world so president
Trump would lose a lot of
maneuverability if he were to pull
troops out of Germany where for example
people might be surprised to learn is
the headquarters of the u.s. Africa
Command so yeah we don't we don't
understand it
people who are looking at this from a
military standpoint you're in Brussels
Terry where NATO has its headquarters
how has NATO reacted to these reports of
a possible US withdrawal in from Germany
well as you know NATO's job is to keep
calm and carry on and make sure nobody
gets too nervous and in fact I had the
chance to ask the Secretary General
Stoltenberg a question about the rumors
of the of the troop pullout earlier this
week and his answer was so blend he said
what were in constant discussion with
the United States about troop
deployments in you
he didn't address the question directly
at all in fact he did have a phone call
with President Trump after this event
where I spoke to him and even after that
NATO officials wouldn't confirm that
President Trump had even informed
Secretary General Stoltenberg about any
specific plans for a troop pullout so we
do have some some reports that a
president Trump might like to move
troops to Poland which does spend 2% of
its of its budget on defense but that
raises other questions about whether
troops US troops should be deployed that
close to the Russian border and there's
just hasn't been any any definition on
these these stories yet but there is a
NATO defense ministerial next week where
defense secretary mark s Perot will be
getting very pointed questions
well this proposal which we have to say
is unconfirmed it's already drawing
criticism though from politicians and
defense analysts on both sides of the
Atlantic
how likely is it Terry that this
withdrawal of American troops in Germany
will actually happen briefly if you can
you think I can't read President Trump
better than anyone else but this is a
reason why people aren't getting too
agitated about it yet you never know if
these things floated out of the White
House are actually going to happen or if
his military officials will have enough
influence on him to get this pulled back
before it actually goes into effect
Terry thank you so much that was DW
correspondent teri Schultz in Brussels
well Berlin isn't the only ally coming
under pressure from the Trump
administration the White House is also
asked Japan to significantly boost its
contribution to maintaining American
forces the US has guaranteed Japan's
defense since the end of World War two
it has more than 50,000 personnel
stationed at facilities across the
country
Washington puts the price tag at some
5.7 billion dollars much of which is
already paid for by Japan the
cost-sharing agreement is due to be
renegotiated next year Japan is already
spending more on defense but on its own
forces
soldiers practice landing amphibious
vehicles and a picturesque Bay on
Japan's Self Coast drive out open the
hatch
close the hatch and then head back to
the beach
it's as if they were planning to set off
for new Shores sometime soon and perhaps
they are but the officer in command is
not allowed to talk to us about that
it's important to train the soldiers one
is the driver once the helmsman it's not
always easy to make a team out of them
according to its constitution Japan
isn't supposed to have an army and many
wanted to stay that way
we don't want Japan to fight in wars all
over the world not even on America so
that's why we're against the drills
even so Tokyo seems to be preparing to
enter the military world stage the
Defense Minister recently deployed this
destroyer to the Gulf of Oman in an
interview he says it's a completely
harmless mission taro kono is aware of
his own power he wants to become Prime
Minister
would you Penn like to play a more
active role military role on the world
stage
we believe sending our destroyer to the
region to get enough information to
secure the pass safes passage of
Japanese or Japan related ships
important for us so that's why we're
sending it we're not part of a American
initiative nor European nor Iranian
initiative it's strictly on our own
isn't that risky I mean there could be
some kind of conflict and you are right
in it
why should we be in it but if everything
is fine why you need a warship in the
region well we need to get the
information to secure the safe passage
of our tankers or other ships so we are
sending them for information gathering
what's wrong with that
just a reconnaissance mission
some people see it differently u.s.
Asian relations expert Glenn Fukushima
for example finds the idea amusing no I
think as defense minister that's what he
had to say you know just as when queasy
me was asked in the diet is it not
dangerous for the self-defense force to
be in combat zones he said well if the
self-defense force is there by
definition that is not a combat zone so
that was his answer behind the scenes of
us Japanese military relations the mood
is less easygoing than here
American military unit stationed here
still may train for aid missions with
the Japanese for earthquakes for example
but since Washington has demanded much
more money from Japan for US troops
tensions have risen considerably it is
actually cheaper to have a Marine
stationed in Japan than to have them in
San Diego so if we pay mother now then
they will become sort of mercenary and I
don't think you were supported would
like to do that harsh words especially
coming from in otherwise loyal Japan is
a possible future government leader
seeking to expand his influence in a big
way insiders say there is support for
this in the ruling party but less so
amongst the Japanese people
for more now I'm joined by Rob Mason
he's a Japanese foreign policy expert at
the University of East Anglia in the UK
thanks for joining us dr. Mason do you
think the Japanese defense minister aims
to formally develop a national military
force and if so why yes in the in the
long run
definitely the aim will be to develop a
formal Defence Force this is because the
Constitution which was after all
Japanese Constitution is American
drafted and American imposed
Constitution has been unchanged for
something like seventy years and this is
very unusual as a national constitution
of a state with Japan's status so
ultimately this is about making small
constitutional revisions which normalize
Japan's international role how do you
explain the Trump administration
demanding that Japan significantly boost
is spending on American troops that's
really about domestic politics so from
the Trump side and from the Japanese
side I mean in this case we've been
talking about Defense Minister corn
apparel but really this is at the
leadership level so this goes up to
Prime Minister Abbott both of them have
a domestic political agenda which can be
played into through this kind of
backwards and forwards over defense
spending on the Trump side he would
obviously like to demonstrate that he
was is coming out of the the current
crises still in a position of strength
and still dictating to his allies and
partners overseas how America thirst
will work and he's about showing he's
doing something for the American economy
on the Japanese side
Prime Minister Abe a for a long time has
wanted to make more use of the Japan
self-defense forces and to be able to
justify that now you might be able to do
that by playing off the demands of Trump
against the protesters or those that
would oppose his upgrading of the
Japanese military so in other words
justify spending money on Japan instead
of spending money on having American
troops there right how do you see this
dispute between Washington and Tokyo
playing out I think that's a difficult
question but you know as I suggested
before I think there is a sense in which
these two positions Japan's and the
United States are actually aligned in an
underlying way that's to say that on the
surface both the defense minister in
Japan Colonel taro and president Trump
have to share a kind of strong stance
they're sticking up for their domestic
audiences but in fact those two
positions are quite well aligned because
if the Trump administration can demand
that Japan pay more Japan can then
justify actually spending more on their
own military rather than spending it on
the American military so there might be
kind of little bit of a back back and
forth a little bit of a kind of show of
negotiation and then the two allies will
ultimately come to quite an agreeable
mutually acceptable position dr. Mason
thank you very much that was dr. Rob
Mason Japanese foreign policy expert at
the University of East Anglia